about this now and with a behind the
founder of wise oceans
Abbi thank you very much indeed for your
time this morning and first of all tell
us about and how what wise oceans do and
what your what your aim is well where's
oceans is a marine education and
conservation organization and so our
main focus is really to get people
educated a bit more about our marine
environment we're a global organization
so we're about educating people wherever
possible about how incredible our oceans
are and tied in with that how best
everyone can play their part in keeping
them clean and healthy for the benefit
of all of us how much worse has the
problem of ocean pollution got and since
you've been working with them yeah thing
every time most of us certainly my team
or whenever we're in the water
snorkeling scuba diving walking along
beaches it's becoming more and more
evident how much marine litter there is
around
so these beach cleans are absolutely
fantastic thing to do and then on the
other hand we tried very much to
encourage people to reduce their use of
plastic in the first place so then
limiting the amount that ends up on the
beaches and why okay better seems this
very simple question when you look at
someone like Joe on the beach clean
there why don't we just pick up after
ourselves question I think a lot of it
does come down to to maybe there aren't
the resources they're like bins or
things like that and so there's still
the attitude of sort of well it's it's
not it's not my problem or it's out of
sight out of mind
and there's an element of laziness as
well and it certainly is very much
everyone's responsibility our planet is
here for all of us and we need to all
take that care to look after it and yeah
just adding a few little things into our
daily lives making sure maybe in our bag
or in our car we've got a cloth bag sent
to the supermarket rather than using a
single-use bag just small little things
carrying a reusable water bottle with us
and things like that we're trying to put
together lots of blobs and information
for people to add those steps into their
daily lives we can all make small
improvements Abbey thank you very much
for your time this morning
appreciate you speaking to us don't
forget by the way you can get involved
with skies ocean rescue campaign go to
sky and rescue comm show us your support
maybe you're doing a beach clean you can
use the hashtag Oh sand rescue on social
media